[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar modernization of tissue-based
biomarker-led clinical research
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab routes and brought to
you by leica biosystems to learn more
visit leica biosystems.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
stephanie craig lecturer in precision
medicine at the patrick g johnson center
for cancer research queens university
belfast
dr craig you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for the introduction and thank
you like a bad system for giving me the
opportunity to speak today today i'm
going to present on modernization of
tissue based biomarker led clinical
research using some examples from our
laboratory to show to demonstrate how
modernization of these techniques has
really helped the research based on
tissue-based research
so one of the things we want to talk
about is how modernization has really
advanced in the last number of years in
tissue based research um pathology has
been around for a long time but it's
only really been the last 20 years we've
seen
an advancement in the field particularly
for researchers and this is mainly
because of the introduction of auto
scanners so automated systems of um
being able to stain um samples that
could be assessed by pathologists
and by create by introducing our singers
it means now we can look at
standardizations of protocols and robust
methods of analyzing tissues and this
has led to the development of new
systems
advanced biomarker systems to
detect um proteins or targets in the
tissue and this may be through this
through use of novel probe designs
through rna scope and dna paint
or through um advances in polymer
technology or
fluorescent dyes to detect the tissues
through the opal or ultraplex systems or
integrating these feeding platforms with
sequencing platforms through the
accu-site or knowing more increasingly
the journal it's um dsp platforms
but what are the considerations we need
we need to understand um to really
utilize these auto seniors and these
systems to their best advantage as a
researcher we need to appreciate the
tissue that we're analyzing um we need
it we need to appreciate what type of
tissue type it is is it's in the breast
is it a brain tissue uh different
different types of tissue may be
affected by the succession process has
been formally fixed is it fresh frozen
is it miscarrying some more unusual
types of fixation
um how old is sample is it prospective
for what we're looking at so we can
control all these factors or is an older
sample where um
it may have been technically blocked 20
years ago or it may have been a cut
section dipped in wax all these factors
will affect um how the how the steam
process is undertaken and even then how
the sample is processed in the first
place and stored what will affect um our
staining process
due to the due to how long pathology has
been run as a clinical practice a lot of
the tissue components we can't really
control and are quite standardized
within the literature and
in this research space
more interestingly for us is the stadium
procedures that's available
so this is one of the biggest
considerations and what i mean by this
is what type of scene are we going to
use are we using routine routine
echinacean to the structural um
structural components of the tissue are
you going to use a special stain
or are we going to look at using a more
targeted method such as chemistry to
look at specific proteins or in situ
hybridization methods to
look at specific dna or protein or dna
rna targets in the tissue
and it depending on what type of stem we
decide to use this will affect what type
of processing they undertake uh do we
have to use um
very thin sections quite thick sections
they have to consider what's what's
first in and what's our way when you cut
the sections to prepare for this
and from that well if we're going to
take these sections how are we going to
process them are we going to hand it
them using several different baths um of
dyes or we're going to automate this
process using a system
and if we are using a system um are we
going to use commercial reagents so
we're standardized we can buy them in
bulk or we're going to uh to um
develop them in-house to use these
processes which can have a lot more
variation in the stain that's produced
in a large sample size
and then also for looking at more
specific techniques such as venus
chemistry and situ hybridization what's
our choice of antibody what there's the
other design
or probe design choice this can have a
significant impact on how sensitive and
specific our assay will ultimately be
and this can be affected by the antigen
retrieval method we choose um if we're
trying to do a manual method we can use
manual steaming we can use a pressure
cooker
um or more novel techniques with antigen
retrieval if we're using an automated
system we might be limited to
heat based with a ph six or ph9 or
enzymatic based on evidence retrieval
and hot what type of detection system
we're using are we using a bright field
detection system or are we using
fluorescent detection system all of
these things are important to consider
whenever we're looking at conducting
tissue based in situ analysis and if
possible simplifying standardizing
automating these processes makes it much
easier to compare assays and to really
interrogate the tissue in an appropriate
manner and in our lab a great example of
this is looking at hpv status
in oropharyngeal cancers now if you're
not familiar with oropharyngeal cancers
and the orifanx is heading if it's part
of the head and neck
and it specifically is the very back of
the throat um the two tonsils back
through the tongue and that very back
wall no other part of the mouth and the
reason why this er this trajectory shoe
type is important in head and neck
counters is because cancer can develop
due to smoking and alcohol related um
risk factors but also due to hpv
infection
and hpv infection can be detected using
the surrogate biomarker known as p16
allowing us to stratify patients into
two distinct phenotypes hpv negative and
it should be positive and this does have
implications for a patient outcome
but as i said there we use a circuit
biomarker and there's been advances in
the technology for um biomarker
detection so in our lab we looked at
different methods of assessing hiv
testing and what will be the best test
we could use to identify it for these
thousand patients
using an epidemiological or pharyngeal
court from northern ireland we took
patient samples and sent them for hpv
genotyping to um a reference lab in the
uk and also took created tissue
microarrays in order to do tissue based
analysis using protein-based dna and
rna-based tests
we ran the p-16 through a reference lab
and assessed it based on the western
criteria where we had either moderate or
strong staining of greater than seventy
percent of tissue was considered a p16
positive case and therefore likely to be
hpv related
we also run rna-ish into
characterization using the rna scope um
zed probe design
and assess them for the presence or
absence of this brand precipitate on
samples
we also run
hpv dns using the traditional methods
and an alkaline phosphatase detection
system um which you can see a slightly
different um visual appearance
so after assessing all these samples
using the four tests we then collated
the results for the positive cases and
the genotyping results and seeing how
closely they related and what we find is
that for the surrogate biomarker p16
both tissue based dna ish and rnah tests
were always positive when p16 was
interchangeable positive or and it means
cancer is positive
um however the hpv genotyping which was
a dna pcr based test was the only test
that identifies cases or p16 negative
hpv positive
so we looked more closely at the
tissue-based phenotypes we found
and as you can see here we have cases
that were
positive by all three tests p16 immune
chemistry hpv rna and hpv dnash weight
cases are p16 positive and hpv rna-ish
positive but dna-ish negative which
supports the use of the novel probe
design from rna scope
and where cases that were unusually p16
positive and hpv positive are actually
the negative by both rna and dna tests
in addition to negatives by all three
tests
we looked at sensitivity and specificity
of these tests against um
b16 staining we found that all three
tests the dna ish rna agent genotyping
were all equally sensitive but the
tissue-based tests were much more
specific than the dna-based pcr
so we wanted to interrogate these a bit
further see well did these phenotypes
the p16 positive hv
negative scene type really exist and
does the p16 positive um like p16
negative hpv
hpv positive phenotype really exists
so using a time trend analysis
we assessed the occurrence of p16
negative h3 positive patients for all
three tests across the time period
gathered to the patients and as you can
see there's only one line in this graph
and that's because only the genotyping
identified cases like this and as you
can see there's actually a bias where
the older the sample was the more likely
we were going to find it being called
hpv positive by genotyping indicating
that actually the hppg may not be no um
specific test it would be used for this
assay
in contrast when we looked at the p16
positive hpv negative patients we
identified this phenotype across all
three tissue based tests in relation to
p16 and there's no time bias here uh in
this assessment
and the reason why this is important
that we're able to identify this
phenotype using these different tissue
based tests is because the surrogate
biomarker p16 identifies patients who
have really good survival versus per
survival with the related hpv status
when we look at the sub uh the subtype
of p16 positive hpv negative in relation
to survival we find that these patients
actually behave more like an hpv
negative disease and considering them
hpv-positive through p-16 assessment
alone would not be appropriate
and in particular this phenotype is a
very rare phenotype across the time
period occurring in less than 10 cases a
year but if it is present and we
wouldn't have been able to detect it if
we hadn't been able to use
a modernized system to robustly assess
these um
different assays in conjunction with
each other
so why is it important to understand
what the acid is detecting and the
limitations in sensitivity and
specificity
well in head and neck cancers and
enormous cancer specifically
um if we positive disease tends to
present in patients with larger neck
nose compared to negative disease and
traditionally the cnn staging for
oropharyngeal cancers wasn't able to
accurately stratify patients for outcome
uh some very clever people in the united
states developed a new method of
clinically staging patients adjusting
for p16 status
um using the size of the illnesses of
the neck nodes
we applied this um new staging system to
our cover retrospectively and find that
we were not able to accurately stratify
patients um more for survival outcome in
their pharmacist p16 related
however this subgroup of p16 positive
hpv negative patients still existed in
this cohort and if only p16 staging that
p16
classification was used for these
patients for the new staging system
95 percent of those patients will be
understated under the new system
so this gives you an idea of why it's
important to understand your assay
limitations but more more than that why
it's important to consider um using
these novel methods these novel methods
uh the how we can identify rare
phenotypes because it may have clinical
implications and some of this work has
went forward to with others has looked
forward to making changes in the uk
guidelines to look at hpv status and
head and neck counselors
but this brings a new question what do
we do in terms of controls we understand
from traditional um immune chemistry
when we need to look at positive and
negative controls in the tissue we look
at the positive tissue and we run our
antibody and we use a negative a
negative tissue and another antibody and
then we can genuinely understand that
our tissue is negative or positive for
our antibody of interest
this new technology with rna scope or
even using such hybridization how do we
know that we can trust sustaining being
produced when we when in sequencing
analysis we have housekeeping genes
so alongside rna scoops new probe design
they also introduced the use of
housekeeping um genes through through
the probes
now in our lab we assessed what would be
the best way to assess the housekeeping
use in these tissues so we can robustly
assess them for rna scope analysis
um so they have three different um
housing teams available um and if we
look here at higher multiplication you
can see that they're varying expression
levels low moderate and high expression
level using digital image analysis we
assess these um in tumor regions and in
stroma regions
and we find most consistently in
prospective samples which have been
controlled for their fixation and that
ppib assessment tumor was the most
robust method
of assessing how good a quality the
tissue would be for
um
quality a quality assessment for rna
scope analysis by a novel biomarker
um so we went back to our retrospective
core of colon samples and using a
qualitative metric of um ppib scoring
from zero to three we assess all of our
samples um visually for their ability to
be included in um
assessment of the novel biomarker and as
you can see here there is varying
quality of and the rna available in each
of the tissues
so whenever we assess then our bond
works of interest pdl1 rna scope and um
cement by rna scope and can combine
compare this to our vp scoring you can
see here consistently that low ppv ppib
score was associated with a low pdl1 and
cmt score
indicating that when the
tissue quality may not be as good this
affects the ability of the rna scope
probe to be assessed using our bone
marker of interest
and as you can see here when there's a
time trend analysis of ppib scoring
across that colon cancer cohort there
was no real effect from time um and it
may have been these samples just for
priority fixed texts in the first
instance when they were being created
and in particular you can see there's a
there's a specific grade there's a
strong association of low p value
scoring with cmet um assessment
indicating that if a ppib scores one or
less
it shouldn't be included for the
assessment of the noble biomarker
and by doing this type of assessment it
means that we can look beyond what we
know clinically that is already accepted
as a biomarker hpv status as well in the
literature as being predictive and
prognostic of um survival in organic
cancers what about if we have a
different cancer type we don't know with
prognosis of the back of the biomarker
um or there may be it's very very
difficult to stratify patients
so using sema as an example um
cement inhibitors have been used with
great effect in other in-laws of cancer
types including lung to um to treat
patients
um however there's been less success of
the use in
other cancer types such as colon for
example for example and part of this is
due to lack of standardization of how to
assess cement um status and patients in
order to um provide their ability to
give them the inhibitor so we decided to
assess using a similar method to h3d
study the
the value of cmips um staining an
expression within a colon cancer cohort
so using the northern irish colon cancer
cohort we assess the patients for for
targets which are normally
utilized in lung cancer
looking at genetic aberrations so using
target target sequencing and looking at
net amplification
we also looked then as cement staining
using immune chemistry and which has
been also used quite widely for patient
stratification and when providing young
people as the
fema inhibitor in addition to rna scope
and we only looked at cases for the rna
scope which have passed our quality
assessment by for the ppib scoring from
this analysis we found that in the colon
setting
very few patients actually had a
metallic aberration
however whenever we compare and compound
combined with cement rna and cnet
protein expression we were able to
identify patients who may
who not only had a very poor prognosis
but also more likely to benefit from
that inhibition because they demonstrate
true men addiction
in the samples
so modernization of the all of these
techniques not only allows us to
robustly identify these rare phenotypes
it's not allowing us to combine the the
test to identify these phenotypes
um but this is this is not the only
thing that came along with um
modernization of the technology we're
also seeing computational dances a lot
um in addition to the
wet lab advancements these computational
advances came along alongside the
atmospheres the introduction of whole
size scanners to
digitize these images and commercial
then this resulted in the release of
commercial image analysis software for
whole site imaging and then more
recently um open source methods of
assessing these whole site images such
as qpass and now we're seeing more and
more and more in literature the
application of deep convolutional neural
network networks and more modern methods
of ai being applied these whole face
histological images and to stratify
patients
and we've been able to use these
computational advances in our ads to all
to our benefit to conduct research at
scale
for example
in this colon cancer cohort we wanted to
look at well how is immune status
prognostic what sort of measures of
immune status are important to consider
using eight different biomarkers across
the court of around 1800 patients from
three different sites in the uk
we were able to generate tissue
microarrays and take um slides for
staining
and using a leica bond rx stain each one
of these sides was eight different
biomarkers very robustly and we actually
only had to restain one sample and so
less than 0.5 percent of samples had to
be restained for um
to pass quality control
and from this um wet lab experiment we
were then able to digitize this
information using
the imperial 82 scanner so that they
could be processed by digital image
analysis to create digital results
and what's great about it being able to
do this type of research and scale is
all these immune bond markers are quite
nuclear
so we were able to then take these
samples
uh these digital uh these digital tissue
microarrays
derive them and conduct cell detection
and positive cell and positive cell
detection for each of the different
biomarkers of interest and we were able
to complete this at scale generating
around 50 000 novel data points for ihc
data
and this digitization of the data meant
then we could use um sophisticated um
physical techniques to look at grouping
subgroupings present in the cohorts and
how these potentially could affect
survival
and once we identify a good survival
strat stratifier
because this data is now digital we can
integrate it with other data sets
digital multi-ohmic data sets
so we then combine this data with
tissue micro
with rna microarrays
and to see if well is there is there
this um
is there transcriptional subtype with
this phenotype we've identified through
tissue based analysis and it appeared
that there was we did pca plots and when
we did further investigations using heat
bats we found there was a specific
number of genes which were associated
with hypoxia
and we just
set gene set enrichment analysis this
signature was very highly enriched
but because we'd start off with tissue
based analysis and combine this with the
other emotional data sets we're then
able to go back into the tissue to
determine if this is a genuine phenotype
we're seeing in the in the other data
sets
and using this we could then specially
assess what is relationship with hypoxia
to the immune biomarkers
and as you can see here when the
patients are immune cold the hypoxia was
very tissue hypoxia is very high within
the tissue the tumor regions
and what this means now for us as
researchers is we can then now begin to
combine different types of data
including tissue based
to start to come up with new hypothesis
for how these patients are are
responding to treatment or how they're
prognostically being defined
prognostically so for example here's our
stratifier in the sub cohort of escort
patients whenever we look at this in
relation to epoxia we see that there's
patients who have very high responses
and a very a very low hypoxia if you do
very well so this may give us a
rationale to start looking at different
measures of assessing
and understanding why patients who have
a good immune response do well for
treatment
so this brings us to the one of our
final considerations for tissue-based
assessment
and this is the biomarker assessment so
we've got very strong rationale for how
we prepare our tissue whatever our
choice of cheap stain is how do we
assess these biomarkers
do we need pathologists or could it be a
non-expert assessment assessing these
through how significance they are
do we do it on the glass stand
microscope or can we do it digitally at
a screen and if we're doing it
positively as a screen should it be
manual should it be digital
and if we're doing in these methods
what's our actual scoring method are we
using percentage are we using area are
we using number of positive pixels
what's the difference what what
difference does that make for for the
pathologist or the image analyst
conducting this research
whatever scanner is also important if we
decide to digitize this
these samples then different scanners
may introduce
a you are image artifacts by changing
the colors um present in the image to
make them look more like you're looking
down a microscope
um what magnification is also important
it depends on what how you're scoring it
and how you're assessing it the
magnification has more or greater effect
and also the long-term storage if you're
digitizing these samples um
how much data will this take up will
still be accessible in 20 years time
with file types change
um
we have to start thinking of these types
of methods we're just starting to do
tissue-based analysis using digital
means
and this is all only for one biomarker
what if we think of doing multiplexing
and we're looking at multiple
lineworkers in a single image and i have
to consider all this um
these factors
so within our lab there is different
methods of multiplexing but we look
specifically at an indirect juvenile
labeling
using the opal detection system
and if you aren't familiar with
multiplexing and multiplexing involves
using
indirect immune labeling where you take
your tissue you apply your primary
antibody followed by your secondary
antibody and then you develop this
product if we're doing um
dab detection it'd be brine if we're
doing multiplex and new fluorescence
it's a fluorescent label
and this method by using fluorescence
allows us to then do repeated rounds of
steeling by applying heat to remove the
previous orange antibodies but leave the
depo the precipitated immunofluorescence
present on the slide this allows us to
go back in the second round of antibody
staining
um with primary in the secondary develop
a different colour
and repeat the process again so on to
force
this one isn't novel this has been
around for a long time we've been able
to do multiple rounds of staining as
long as we don't do music chemistry
however what as i mentioned earlier
there's been advances in the polymer
detection technology and also the dyes
that are available to conduct
fluorescence
one of the problems with using this
indirect immune labeling method is
known as steric hindrance and this
occurs whenever these
dye reaction products are developed too
close to each other
so we wanted to look at this new methods
been produced through opal and see how
difficult would it be to generate a
panel design
in in samples that had co-expression in
the same cellular compartment and its
co-expression different cellular
compartments for immune biomarkers of
interest
and using these methods and then how
difficult it would be to assess these
digitally
so
for this assessment we
we were talking about using repeating
just around the staining
so i mentioned that earlier that the
anti-retrieval is a very important step
to consider with stadium process and the
reason why i said this is because
whenever we formally fix tissue which is
what we tend to use for um
for histological research uh we create
these protein cross links in the tissue
and in order to allow our antibodies to
bind to the tissue we have to um unmask
them using heat and just epitope
retrieval
whenever we're doing repeated rounds of
staining you can start to denature these
proteins present the slide and depending
on the protein or biomarker of interest
they might be more or less affected by
multiple rounds of antigen retrieval
so in order so in this um in this study
we looked at how we could determine the
best method or best order of applying
antibodies in order to obtain the most
accurate representation of the steaming
pattern
so using low and high express expression
um
tissue tissues of interest
we looked at applying our biomarkers to
several different rounds of staining
and you'll see here i'm presenting dab
stealing uh because this is using
indirect immune labeling method we can
actually replace the dye product with
dab for us to better understand how the
steam is behaving when we're doing our
initial optimization process
and as you can see here in our low and
high immune expressing we have variable
um
variable expression depends how stable
the epitope is um after multiple rounds
of heat um and just retrieval and this
allows us to determine what would be the
best order to successfully stain for
antibodies in tissue when we're doing
our panel designs
and once we have an idea of what type of
order for the antivirus will be suitable
we then need to think about well how are
we going to pair them to the multi to
the fluorescent probes we need to
consider where they're situated in the
cell is it in the nucleus is it the
cytoplasm is the cell membrane
and how
how abundant it was in tissue if it's a
very very low levels of abundance we
should we should pair it with a higher
expressive um
fluorophore or with very high expression
tissue we should express it with a lower
expression therefore
and if these are in the same
if if either sample is expressed in the
same compartment we should try and
effectively separate from them so we're
not having overlap of um of dye products
when we're trying to excite the dance
for image always capture
so in order once we've decided you know
based on what we've done there with the
ihc what was the best order and how
we're going to pair them with these out
with these fluorophores we then
conducted this assessment the same
tissue
and compared it directly to our irc
assessment previously
and as you can see here most of the most
of the software's matched up pretty well
to their their dab compartment from um
their their previous previous statistic
iterations however for some there was
some significant differences but when we
look at these more closely it's either
due to the result of it being from a
non-serial section or due to per um cell
detection in the diagnostic chemistry
so this kind of gives us an idea of the
antibody order we apply and also the
the how we pair our opal antibody dyes
up for the multiplex panels
and allows us to do our first round of
multiplex stealing on on on our system
so during our stay our proceeding
process we then able to review how well
our multiplex designs worked and as you
can see here
we look more closely our cd20 has some
overlap into the cd8 channel
um our cytokeratin has some overlap into
our cd4 and cdhl and this is due the
cd20 cd8riship is due to a thing called
spectral bleed through both of these
antibodies um
we use various uh to use two spectral
dyes which are very closely arranged so
by changing the two the the two
different dyes used whereas better
especially separate and not have a seed
through in later iterations of staining
process
and the cytokeratin we were able to
change around our antibody order that
has been applied and these fluorescent
thermophores are much more sensitive
than dab reaction products so even
though something looks so it might be a
good fit um by the dab assessment
initial assessment whenever you start to
pair it with the third force you may see
it's more sensitive than previously
anticipated
um another thing to look at as well for
when you're doing your optimization of
the multiplex if you're starting to use
panel design and
i'm planning on systems for optimization
um is does your heat after it's heating
just epitope retrieval successfully
remove
um your previous run to stealing and the
reason why this is important um
particularly if you're doing manual
staining is whenever you're doing your
heating just down to retrieval if you
have only partial removal of your
previous round staining when you do your
second round of find your primary
antibody in your secondary
you may then start to develop
a secondary product for a first and
product on inappropriate targets for
non-specific staining and the easiest
way to check for this is by running drop
by controls where you apply your round
of antibody staining your marker of
interest that you're interested in with
its third floor of interest
and in the next round of staining
omit the antibody for that round but
apply the flour for to confirm that you
have um complete removal of the previous
round of
antibody stealing
and after several successive iterations
you'll eventually develop your body flex
panel of interest
the reason
why it's so important to consider all
these is this is only the wet lab
validation um and by using an automated
system we can control a lot of the uh
a lot of
a lot of additional factors and through
using commercial reagents or by having
the system using um using specific times
and heat settings
this means it's simpler for us to
optimize by just changing small factors
like the antibody concentration or the
antibody opal pairings
um
or even the order of steeling
but we also have to start to start
considering we're looking multiplex uh
the digital assessment how are we going
to create these digital images and i
mentioned previously that the importance
of magnification when looking at the
specific um biomarkers of interest in
fluorescent staining the magnification
is directly related to the amount of
fluorophore emitted
so because the
the fluorescence light comes through the
microscope lens if you scan at times 20
versus times 40 you'll actually have
brighter signals from times 20 scan than
the times 40 scan um and depending on
the biomarkers of interest this may be
may be more or less important depending
on what you're looking at we didn't find
a difference in our study but it may be
something to consider
another thing to consider relating to um
the
excitation of the fluorophores is your
exposure times if you over expose in a
channel you can create artifacts of the
odd present staining that may be
misinterpreted as um genuine staining
when you're doing your digital image
analysis because it's created on the
image as an artifact
and you can look at this by looking at
individuals exposures versus batch
exposures in the tissues
and
if you're like us and use a more
advanced system and look at
multi-spectral infrastructure imaging
instead of using a fluorescent camera
with narrow band pass filters you can
now begin to look at um how well your
samples have been prepared by the
outlook and the other process channel to
see if they're particularly thick or
thin sections
and this may affect the quality of
things produced and
further to that how effectively spectral
mixing allows us to assess separate
channels
and the reason why this is important is
because in multiplex and in any
fluorescent um assessment
unlike bright field images
every channel in a multiplex image has
unique information in it
and this is this is particularly
important to understand you think of the
digital analysis because the order in
which you apply your levels of
self-detection may have a very minor
influence on the number of cells
detected or could have a very major
influence depending how well you've been
able to optimize your unfolding panel in
the first instance
so how do we assess this in our in our
study we decided to look at the best way
of
doing quality assessment on our
multiplex analysis was through using a
multi-tissue tma block where we've
stained it for the dab markers of
interest using our single flex
assessment and are all also our two
multiplex panels of interest
using different tissue types to get a
different range of staining patterns
and we assessed according to single pegs
and multiplex um a single biomarkers and
combining the open find the assessments
and as you can see here
when we talk about our two different
panel designs our multiplex panel one
which had co-expression in the same
cellular compartment and required more
rounds of um multiplex optimization for
the wet lab work
was also the most um problematic in
terms of the order of in which they and
the cells were detected and quantified
in the tissue
where you may have certain biomarkers
going from being 75 to example to 44
percent of the sample
in contrast our co-expression
differential apartments so we looked at
the multiplex panel 2 only took two
rounds of a
wet lab optimization and consistently
show demonstrated similar quantification
quantities across all different measure
orders of biomarkers applied in digital
image analysis
so it's important as you guys can see
here study it's important to consider
how the wet lab work influences your
digital analysis but what happens if we
can't control our wet lab or our digital
components what if we only received
as a researcher an image to work on and
increasingly we are seeing in the
literature the use of artificial
intelligence being used on hne images
from anywhere in the world um being used
to develop models
for um patient stratification
but oneness but this type of analysis is
still hindered by the similar problems
we've got from other tissue based
research where we're having a
significant variation in staining
quality produced just because it's from
different labs and different types of
hemitoxin and asm batches could be used
so we looked at this in our lab um
and developed a tool to help clean off
these images that we can get from
different sources where we can't control
the pre-analytical factors of the wet
lab factors
and using this tool called histoclean we
can text images break them up into tiles
more suitable for for you for artificial
applying artificial intelligence
um
and we can then take them and start to
tie them up by removing the tiles
they've got significant areas of white
space
we can take the tiles compare them to a
color palette where we know is more
relevant to us to adjust the color
ranges
and we can also start to apply some
basic augmentations which may be
beneficial to the artificial tangent
intelligence model depending what you're
looking at
so in order to see how beneficial you
know applying these types of
augmentations with the image
pre-processing
we took um
data that was going to be used for
artificial intelligence model and
applied the different methods available
through histogram on the images before
determine before
developing the model um simultaneously
and taking our oropharyngeal cohort
again we assess the patients for
stronghold maturity and stromal
immaturity
and using different types of
augmentations find that by just adding
some simple applications you get a
significant approval and model accuracy
so just change the limitations that
change the image source not changed in
tissue type just very small minor
adjustments and this is we find just by
adding enhancing the features of the
stroma the fibrous and stroma and by
balancing the dataset we saw significant
improvement
so hopefully today i've been able to
demonstrate to you the benefit of using
an automated steering platform
for to perform your tissue based
research uh but using these platforms is
much easier to optimize and complex
mystic chemistry and situ hybridization
protocols and once you have an optimized
assay to reproduce this in your large
cohort studies at scale and in addition
to using these automated platforms it
makes it much easier to standardize
these protocols um particularly within
new technologies and not allowing for
direct comparison of and the new ms
chemistry and institute hybridization
and staining procedures this means now
we can look at identifying where
phenotypes with confidence um in these
vertical in these big cohort studies
and further to that um hopefully i've
shown to you that whole site imaging um
is of a benefit in this field and
enables quantitative and sensitive
analysis
of um of biomarker studies and enables
data sharing
to um
to further exist research
it also allows us because the data is
digitized to integrate the image data
with not multiple datasets and take it
forward for use in artificial
intelligence studies
um
with this in mind um the considerations
we had previously of tissue dna
biomarker assessment
prior to optimization and modernization
of these techniques in the laboratory
most of our times the research will be
spent optimizing the tissue and staining
process with limited time for biomarker
assessment
whereas now with automation and whole
site imaging where we'll spend less time
optimizing the essays and more time
assessing the biomarkers in novel ways
so with that in mind um thank you for
listening i'd like to acknowledge my
principal investigators professor jackie
james and professor madison fellas as
well as the researchers involved with
data creation and cooperation of in the
head net cohort and in the colorectal
cohorts as well as the funders thank you
very much for listening and i'll take
any questions
thank you dr craig for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
what do you believe is the biggest
barrier to translating novel techniques
such as multiplex immunofluorescence
into clinical practice
all right so
for me one of the biggest barriers for
multiplex or any of these more novel
techniques
is the
ability to access quality assessments
assurance schemes
so we think within the uk we've got uk
class to make sure that we're all using
um similar quality of metrics for the
quality of the biomarker assessment
using itc um it's getting procedures
like that in place that we want we've
got this technology in the labs and we
use it routinely we can confirm that
everyone's doing the same sort of tests
so that's probably for me the biggest
barrier not not access to technology but
how how do we make sure that when people
have it in place we know they're all
doing something that's reproducible
great thank you
next question
what steps do you think need to be taken
to ensure ai algorithms in digital
pathology are accepted
so this is similar to the multiplex
question in terms of quality assurance
but it's slightly different because with
ai
with wisdom i mean this chemistry food
procedures this is based in chemistry so
we understand why an obviously works or
it doesn't work because it is very
technical based the difference with um
artificial intelligence measures is a
lot of these algorithms work with big
data
and they
they work very very well but they're
more of a black box compared to you know
traditional ihc so probably the biggest
steps for um
to ensure these ai algorithms to be
accepted
um in digital pathology or in clinical
pathology is model explainability
and there's a lot of research going on
in the space to
determine how these models are working
and different different ways to express
that which is what we're trying to show
in our histogram study
thank you
next question
what would be in your opinion
the next new and fundamental technology
in this field
so for me the spatial analysis and what
we're seeing increasingly with
combination of with combinations of
sequencing analysis
is going to be the next big advancement
in this field
and using this in relation to identify
novel phenotypes and novel
um
areas of research that then could be
interrogated using methods like ai but
that's with the wetland technology i
think combinations of
uh sequencing and steering is will be
the next big thing particularly with
fluorescence
thank you
and it looks like we have time for one
more question why do you use qpath
instead of other image analysis software
such as halo
for us this is just more we were
familiar with the open source software
um so it gives us as researchers in our
lab more flexibility um and how to um
assess these images but it's just under
personal preference why we use qpas in
these particular studies
all right well thank you dr craig for
your time today in your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor leica biosystems for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you